if you want to know what will happen
next with covert in the uk
it helps to keep an eye on comparable
countries
this is berlin today thousands of people
protesting against coronavirus
restrictions now much of this
is politically motivated but still these
crowds feel comfortable enough to make
their point
because cases have been low in germany
for several months
is this the future for the uk or
is this paris where masks have been made
mandatory in the street an amazingly
tough measure
given what we know about transmission
outdoors
and this is why cases are rising fast
above the levels recorded back in march
at the very peak of the pandemic and
it's the same in spain which recorded
almost 10
000 cases on friday it's most ever
although we need to be careful both
countries are testing so much
more that they're discovering many more
cases including many milder ones
in many ways this is a false comparison
the situation is different now and you
can see that in this graph of french
deaths
look this time round deaths aren't
rising in line with cases look they're
so low down here
and that might be because there's a lag
but it might also be because this time
around
infections are in younger people who
aren't as affected as severely
by the virus although the worries that
it will start in younger people
then seep into the more vulnerable areas
of the population
and you might have to introduce another
national lockdown
so what does that mean for the uk where
we still have local restrictions
in places like oldham the uk our number
is still around one
and the surveys where we test the same
people week after week
showcase the declining but look here
daily cases are ticking up and schools
are about to open so are we germany
keeping the lid on it or are we france
losing control
they will hope it's the former but
either way we should remember
this isn't march all over again we test
so much more we know so much more about
treatment
and we all understand how to change our
behavior
that is cause for optimism as we face
the uncertain future